think it's been a
more coherent than
you might think with one exception yes
there were some mistakes in the mini
budget which we had to reverse and in
particular I think it's clear you can't
fund tax cuts through increased
borrowing so that's a that is a clear
thing that we changed course on but
taking that aside if you look at uh
you know the industrial strategy you
talk about I think to say that we're
going to be the world's next Silicon
Valley and we're going to be global
leaders in clean energy Life Sciences
digital creative Industries Advanced
manufacturing and to set out how you're
going to do it in terms of improving the
skills base making sure that growth is
spread across the country those are
things that are what anyone would call
an industrial strategy
and so I don't think it's necessary to
publish a new document I just want to
get on and do it if you look at
the big decision
made by Boris Johnson's administration
at the start of the parliament to
increase Capital spending very
significantly
we have
honored that we weren't able to continue
the rate of increase that was originally
planned but we froze the increase at its
higher level in cash terms and that is
um actually I should bring in cat little
because she's in charge of government
spending but I think that is one of the
biggest changes in government economic
policy in recent times that increasing
Capital spending so